Vladimir Putin está en crimea una vez
más Pero esta vez no es en una fecha más
se cumplen nueve años de la anexión de
la Península ucraniana por parte de
Rusia una anexión que fue criticada y
señalada como ilegal por la mayor parte
de los países de Naciones Unidas
Vladimir Putin ha sido visto paseando
por la ciudad de vasto por acompañado de
las autoridades locales ha inaugurado
una escuela para niños inicialmente lo
iba a inaugurar por internet como suelo
hacer últimamente pero finalmente ha ido
en persona causando la sorpresa de
muchos es una visita significativa
porque se produce solo 24 horas después
de que el tribunal Penal Internacional
de la haya emita una orden de arresto
contra Vladimir Putin la acusan de estar
implicado en el supuesto secuestro de
cientos de niños ucranianos tras la
invasión de Ucrania por parte de Rusia
en febrero del año pasado